Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute, Mean.
Also bizi Fair makeup hier mit
Das war's für heute.
Also ich hab, wo sind denn die Sonnenpilze, die hab ich jetzt gar nicht reingepackt.
Bildorder fail.
It's Kiosk.
Hey, du bist ja auch wieder da.
Was, du warst gestern Abend auch da, ne?
Name kommt mir echt bekannt vor.
Das erste war noch gar nicht von EA, das ist richtig.
Das ist bevor PopCap.
CapPop per PopCap.
Von EA gekauft wurde.
Boah, die Musik ist heute echt hardcore.
Aber da müssen wir durch, es ist Weihnachten.
Keine Chance.
Da können wir jetzt nicht dodgen oder so.
Da muss jetzt Weihnachtsmusik, muss jetzt.
Keine Chance.
Ist die Lautstärke von der Musik so in Ordnung?
Oder ist zu laut?
Oh.
Der will gebasht werden.
Uh.
Ich bin so voll, ey.
Ich kann mich überhaupt noch mal konzentrieren.
Ich muss eigentlich jetzt Tribble Nators pflanzen.
Tribble Nators.
Ist er geschreckt?
Der Zombie.
So, jetzt können wir Tribble Nators pflanzen.
Ups.
Ist nicht mehr.
Jetzt wieder.
Jetzt wird er gereckt.
Tyrannosaurus.
Schreckt wird er.
Der Zombie.
Schreckt, schreckt, schreckt.
Kleinen Pilze kosten ja nichts.
Die kann man so oft bauen, wie man will.
Hehehe.
Das Spiel ist doof.
Kann keine Physik-Synoscop-Montages machen.
Ah, guck mal, mein Sonnenflick ist geil, oder?
Hast du den gesehen?
Der Sonnenflick?
Die Mausbeschleunigung in dem Game ist der Wahnsinn.
Huh?
Bam.
Look at that aim.
Moment, ist das deutsch?
Nein, das ist nicht deutsch.
Hattest du angehört?
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht, warum Maria Virgin sein musste.
Aber es macht es wahrscheinlich mysteriöser.
Ich denke also immer, ey, der Josef, da hat wirklich schon die Arschkarte gehabt, ne?
Da ging nichts.
Da wurde nicht weggeflankt damals.
Das war noch Zucht und Ordnung.
Oh, fertig schon.
Easy clap.
Listen, Patrick.
Blub blub blub blub blub.
Die Dinger verwende ich nie.
Die Latern-Dinger braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Man sieht genug, trotz Nebel.
So, das brauchen wir, das brauchen wir.
Sonnenpilz, diesmal machen wir es richtig.
Das da, das da.
Ähm, Blätter.
Nose.
Das da, das brauchen wir nicht.
Äh, dum dum dum dum dum dum.
Äh.
Machen wir mal was anderes.
Ich bin nicht immer nur Trouble-Natern, das wird ja auch langweilig.
Was ist denn immer noch?
Bam.
So.
Haha, Marfin.
Null.
Tja.
Immer noch Tilted von Overwatch?
Nee, aber ich sehe es nicht, einen Rank zu spielen.
Zumindest nicht mehr die aktuelle Season und ehrlich gesagt sehe ich es eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht, einen Rank zu spielen.
Bis das System mal irgendwie auf den grünen Zweig kommt.
Das Overwatch Ranking System ist einfach so der größte Bullshit ever.
Brains.
Tracked.
Ups, Build Order Fail.
Hast du wenigstens wieder installiert? Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Ey, die Musik macht mich fertig.
Ich muss mich...
Komm, wir machen, wir machen, wir machen das von gestern.
Was hatten wir im Frank Sinatra Christmas Album?
Das war doch, das hat ein bisschen wenigstens ein bisschen Schmackes gehabt, ja.
Ja, das ist doch, das ist doch ein bisschen...
Geht doch was.
Fangen wir mit Rainbow Six an. Ich habe mit dem Eaxe zusammen vor ein paar Tagen gespielt.
Wie gesagt, ich fand das Game schon gar nicht mal so kacke, wie ich es zur Beta fand.
Hier ist mein Video.
Ich habe auch schon Daily Quests und Zeug gemacht.
Also ich müsste jetzt endlich mal auf 60 grinden, ja.
Wir spielen jetzt auch ein bisschen Plants vs. Zombies, vor allem bis ich ein bisschen verdaut habe und das alles wieder ordentlich funktioniert.
Dann können wir, wenn ihr wollt, noch ein bisschen BDO grind spielen.
Ein bisschen BDO auf 60 grind.
Ein bisschen sinnlos im Kreis grinden und mobs bashen.
Frag mich nicht, warum ich den jetzt ausgerechnet dahin gepflanzt habe, keine Ahnung.
Ey, lass den in Ruhe.
Finger weg vom Pilz.
Du du.
Snowen tut es bei uns garantiert nicht.
Ich bin übelst müde.
Macht er platt?
Das sollte jetzt verrecken.
Na ja, kann zwar schon aufpassen.
Snow in 2k17.
Moin Ghost.
Freust du dich 2018 auf irgendwelche Spiele?
Wir müssen uns gleich mal eine Liste angucken, was 2018 eigentlich rauskommt.
Weil selbst wenn ich mich auf ein Spiel freue, ich vergesse immer wann die ganzen Sachen released werden.
Das können wir gleich mal machen.
Wir gucken uns gleich mal eine Release Liste 2018 an.
Was da schönes kommt.
Letztes Video mit dem Frisör, das wahrscheinlich länger sein kann.
Ach, ich glaube, da wird es sich...
Hoffe ich mal.
Nächste Zeit vielleicht noch ein bisschen was ergeben.
Nicht unbedingt wieder 4 Jahre.
Oh nein, da schreckt meine Pilze.
Und dem los.
Das ist richtig ehrenlos, der Zombie.
Ja erlaubt ihn, ich bin auch zaubermäßig müde.
Zu viel gefressen.
Ich bin super Nintendo.
Aus dem dann später die Playstation wurde, weil Nintendo sich gedacht hat, Sony leckt uns am Arsch.
Ich weiß nicht, was da Nintendo wieder geritten hat damals.
Genau, Secret of Mana war nämlich ursprünglich für das Super Nintendo CD Laufwerk gedacht.
Das heißt, das Game hatte mit Sicherheit sehr viel mehr Content geplant.
Vielleicht sogar Renderszenen, was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, was die genau geplant haben.
Wir werden es nie wissen.
Und nachdem Nintendo ja das komplett verschissen hat,
gab es das ja nie, das CD Laufwerk für den Super Nintendo.
Und es gab Secret of Mana in der abgespeckten Version,
was immer noch ein saumäßig geiles Game war mit einem der besten Game Soundtracks überhaupt.
So und jetzt kommt das Remake raus.
Und das Remake sieht so scheiße aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich mein, what the fuck?
Ich mein, ist das ein free to play mobile Game oder was?
Ich mein, wenn ich mir hier schon das Model hier von dem Mädel und der Koboldin angucke,
der Randy, der geht ja noch irgendwie.
Aber da krieg ich echt kurz Reflexe, wenn ich das sehe.
Oder sowas hier.
Also ganz im Ernst, man muss kein Fan von Pixel-Grafik sein.
Und ich hätte auch nichts dagegen, wenn das Spiel in schöner Fake-2D-Grafik gemacht wäre.
Aber das hier, das ist einfach, als hat man, für mich sieht das aus, als hat man keinen Bock gehabt,
Ressourcen zu verschwenden mit Leuten, die ordentliche Models machen, die ordentliche Texturen.
Ich weiß nicht, das spricht mich überhaupt nicht an.
Wenn man sich mal ein paar Bilder anguckt von dem originalen Super Nintendo Game.
Das sah für Super Nintendo Verhältnisse auch nur ganz okay aus.
Das war halt ein Game, das kam so in der Mitte der Lebenszeit.
Aber das war halt echt eine Grafik, die hatte Scham, wenn man sich das so anguckt.
Ich sage gar nicht, dass es genau so aussehen müsste als Remake.
Aber irgendwas so, die gleichen Details, das sieht nicht aus wie in Secret of Mana, das Neue.
Äh, was mache ich denn da?
Ne, also wo wir gerade dabei sind, also, nein, ich weiß gar nicht, ob...
Vielleicht, ich werde mich wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht dazu hinreißen können.
Obwohl, ich weiß, vielleicht kann ich mich doch nicht bremsen und kaufe es mir.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, was kommt denn sonst noch?
März 2018, Far Cry 5.
Das, was ich gesehen habe, sah aus wie Far Cry, seit Ubisoft halt die Far Cry Dinger bastelt.
Also besser gesagt, seitdem es nicht mal Crytek macht.
Also quasi nach Far Cry 1.
Und...
Also mich hat das Setting nicht geschockt von Far Cry 5.
Und noch einmal das Gleiche.
Was ja im Endeffekt 3 und 4 schon mehr oder weniger das gleiche Game waren, bloß unterschiedliche Setting.
Brauche ich nicht.
Pizza Connection 3 könnte vielleicht ganz lustig werden.
Aber juckt mich auch nicht.
Sea of Thieves.
Ich predikte einfach mal, das wird ein Spiel, was mit vielen Ambitionen wird aber failen.
Das ist dieses Piraten-Multiplayer-Spiel auf der Xbox.
Erstens Xbox Lull.
Und zweitens hat man viele coole Szenen gesehen.
Auf den Pressekonferenzen und auch in den Trailern und sowas.
Die große Preisfrage bei sowas ist immer, wenn die immer nur coole Szenen zeigen ist.
Wie fügen die sich zusammen?
Du kannst aus jedem Mist coole Szenen rausschneiden.
Die trashigsten Filme haben ganz coole Trailer teilweise oder zumindest ein cooles Cover.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es was wird.
Aber da bin ich gespannt.
Da bin ich nicht irgendwie gehypt, aber da bin ich echt gespannt.
Away Out sagt mir gar nichts.
Von wem ist das?
Von EA und wer macht's?
Okay, das war ganz nett.
Gefängnisausbruch Simulator.
Das klingt ganz interessant.
Habe ich mich aber noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Das habe ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt, dass es überhaupt schon demnächst kommt.
Der erste Teil war wirklich super.
Also ich muss jetzt mal in mich gehen, bevor ich sage, es gibt kein hübscheres Spiel auf der PS3 als das erste Ni No Kuni.
Aber zumindest vom Style her und sowas ist das erste Ni No Kuni wirklich eines der hübschesten Spiele, die es auf der PS3 gegeben hat.
Das war wirklich ein tolles Game.
Der Far Cry 5 juckt mich nicht. Agony sagt mir nichts. Was ist das? Ist das Gollum oder was soll das? Ist das ein Herr der Ringe Spiel?
Nein. Kickstarter. Na, da warten wir mal ab.
Wizard of Legends. Das ist ja schon ein Titel, der klingt sehr trashig.
Was ist das? Das ist bestimmt ein Mobile-Game. Sagt mir alles nichts.
Warum ist denn die Game-Star-Seite so langsam? Please.
Das war immer. Sagt mir nichts.
Attack on Titan 2 juckt mich auch nicht.
Ash of God's Redemption sagt mir auch nichts.
Ghost of a Tale. Da habe ich mir mal ein paar Sachen auf Steam angeguckt. Das sah ganz interessant aus.
Das ist mit der Maus.
Dieser Maus als Held.
Was ist das? Schleich-Game.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf. Hellpoint sagt mir gar nichts. Moons of Madness sagt mir auch nichts.
Undungeon sagt mir auch nichts.
Ohne Werbung. Ja, wisst ihr was?
Live Adblock Installation. Lul.
Ich muss erst mal gucken, ob ich das richtige installiere.
Ja, das ist das Richtige.
So. Ist es jetzt schneller?
Ha, jetzt ist es schneller. Die Seite sieht auch viel besser aus gleich.
We Happy View. Das verbinde ich irgendwie mit Xbox-Exklusiv und
ein bisschen abgedreht und hat mich auch schon beim Trailer nicht gejuckt. Genau.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Juckt mich nicht. Conan Exile.
Wird das mal wieder gebolten ein bisschen? Ach, das war dieses Survival-Ding.
Nein, das ist ein Negativ-Hype.
Ein neues Metro. Das könnte mich interessieren. Die ersten paar Metro-Games. Zwei gab es.
Drei? Last Light gab es noch. Drei. Ich glaube drei Metro-Games gab es mittlerweile.
Die waren ganz gut.
Pathfinder. Das klingt nach einem RPG.
Könnte was sein. Und das wars. Mehr nicht. Mehr ist noch nicht bekannt, was 2018 kommt.
Laut Wikipedia kommt da, äh, naja.
Also bis jetzt war da nichts dabei, worauf ich mich wahnsinnig freuen würde 2018.
Wo ich ja mal gespannt drauf bin.
Ah, hier oben ist noch mal. Oh, es gibt ein neues Ace Combat.
Das ist so Arcade-Flug-Shooter-Dingszeug.
Da haben mir die Teile früher übelst viel Spaß gemacht. Mal gucken, wie das neu wird.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Ja, wo ich mal wirklich gespannt drauf bin.
Was Camelot Unchained macht nächstes Jahr.
Die erzählen ja schon seit eineinhalb Jahren, dass die Beta demnächst mal startet.
Aber sieht nicht so aus. Da bin ich mal gespannt, was rauskommt.
Eines der wenigen Sachen, die ich gebackt habe damals auf Kickstarter. Mit, ich glaube, und es lacht mich nicht aus.
Ich glaube, mit 300 Euro. Für den Gelb war es wahrscheinlich nie fertig werden.
Bech gehabt. RIP. RIP-Money.
Ey, man muss dazu sagen, Dark Edge of Camelot ist das Game, wo ich mit Abstand,
wirklich mit Riese, mit Meilen weit, Kilometer Abstand, die meiste Spielzeit drinne hab.
Und das ist von dem Typ, der ursprünglich auch Dark Edge of Camelot entwickelt hat.
Oder Chef entwickelt hat. Marc Jacobs.
Und dachte mir so, ey, wenn mal wieder irgendwas in dieser Richtung rauskommt, da muss man das supporten.
Das waren natürlich auch rosarote Brille, ja.
In 2018 könnten einige gute Konsolenexklusiv-Titel kommen.
Hast du da eine Liste, wo wir mal gucken können? Da können wir uns hier noch zusammen angucken.
Also post einfach mal eine Link, wenn du eine gute Liste und gute Übersicht hast über Konsolenspiele 2018.
Hast du dir mittlerweile Pupke mal wieder angesehen? Nein.
Ich wette mit euch, die Performance ist noch genauso schlecht.
Moin xKillards. Das ist richtig klassischer Call of Duty Quickscope-Name. xKillards.
Also damit hättest du früher Montages machen können. xKillards HD Production Presents.
Und dann MW2 Rust, 180 Kreisel vom Turm runter mit der Intervention.
Wer erinnert sich bestimmt noch da ein oder andere dran?
Also wir sehen nichts, aber unsere Pilze werden das ganze schon regeln.
Ich muss sagen, Weihnachten diesmal ist das erste seit Jahren, wo ich eigentlich ganz nett finde.
Und jetzt mal überhaupt nicht aus irgendwelchen christlichen Geschichten, das ist mir total egal.
Die werden jetzt einmal plattgefahren.
Ja, endlich kann man das denn ein bisschen wegpusten. Warum habe ich 155 Zuschauer? Alter, warum?
Okay, ich habe ein paar Sachen übersehen im Chat.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal Xbox und PS4 Games an, aber vorher lese ich mal Chat.
Äh, Aschenden kann ich dir leider nichts zu sagen. Wir haben gestern ein bisschen zusammen geguckt, aber für 5 Euro fällt mir nichts rein.
Hey, ich habe eine Frage. Mein selbst gebauter Rechner geht sofort wieder aus, wenn ich ihn einschalte. Woran liegt das?
Hast du alle Stromkabel angeschlossen? Mal ganz doof gefragt. Also sprich, das fette ATX-Kabel und diese kleinen 4-Pin-Dinger.
Sind dir irgendwelche Schrauben reingefallen oder so?
Ich tippe mal drauf, du hast nicht alle Stromkabel angeschlossen. Man kann das nämlich auch sein, dann drückst du Power on, geht der Lüfter kurz an und gleich wieder aus.
Also du musst mal gucken, du musst das ATX-Kabel reinstecken. Je nachdem, wenn daneben noch Platz ist, dann musst du da noch einen 4-Pin reinstecken.
Aber aktuelle Netzteile haben quasi schon den ATX-Stecker, der breit genug ist. Ich glaube 24-Pin.
Und dann brauchst du noch eins bis zwei weitere 4-Pin Stecker, die du aufs Mainboard machen musst. Wenn du die nicht drauf machst, dann geht es nicht an, wenn du Pech hast.
Ja ja, ich weiß, was FFZ ist, einfach normal. Aber das schöne an Bella Twitch TV ist, Bella Twitch TV Emotes funktionieren mit Bella Twitch TV und FFZ. Umgedreht nicht.
Gibt es die Kaktäne nur im Shop vom Dave? Nein, die kriegt man hier nach Level beenden.
Ok, auch nochmal lange Frage. Wenn wir gerade bei PC sind, mein PC bleibt circa einmal wöchentlich beim Spielen einfach hängen, tut sich nichts mehr.
Als ich noch die Soundkarte trenne, hat sich der Sound dann geloopt. Ohne Soundkarte bleibt er einfach nur hängen. Woran könnte das liegen?
Das kann ja an fast allem liegen. Von RAM kaputt bis zu heiß, das kann ja fast alles sein.
Wobei ich mal drauf tippen würde, irgendwelche komischen Herstellertreiber oder so die merkwürdige Dinge machen. Wenn wirklich RAM kaputt wäre, dann hättest du wahrscheinlich öfters Probleme.
Und überhitzen wird wahrscheinlich auch nichts. Davon kackt er in der Regel auch nicht ab. Was du machen kannst, du kannst mal einen RAM-Test machen, ob es da nicht wirklich Probleme gibt.
Ansonsten kann das alles sein, wenn der Rechner einmal in der Woche hängen bleibt. Das ist einfach sogar irgendein Windows-Bug.
Wie bist du eigentlich auf die Idee gekommen, wieder Plants vs. Zombies zu zocken? Weil ich gestern, nachdem ich mich voll gefressen habe, gedacht habe, ich könnte noch mal eine Runde streamen.
Da habe ich irgendwann ein Game gebraucht, was man von halb GnRfk spielen kann. So, und jetzt gucken wir uns mal Games an für PS4 und Xbox.
Kann man eigentlich nur die CPU austauschen, ohne weitere Änderungen? Ja, kannst du machen. Warum auch nicht?
Du musst gucken, dass die CPU von deinem Mainboard unterstützt wird, dann kannst du einfach die CPU austauschen. Das ist kein Ding.
Überprüft Windows nicht bei jedem Start in RAM, keine Ahnung, ob das Windows macht, aber es kann kein großartig ausführlicher Test sein, weil es geht viel zu schnell.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal Games an für die PS4. Was da so rauskommt. Display Capture. Bam.
Also, PS4-Spiele 2018. Was haben wir da so Schönes? Nino Kuni 2, das haben wir gerade schon gesehen. Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Definitiv eines der hübschesten Spiele auf der PS3. Ok, ein Remake, was die Welt nicht braucht. Also versteht mich nicht falsch, das war ein super Game.
Aber das gab es schon mal, Remake auf die PS3. Und nochmal. Wobei man schauen muss, wie sie es machen. Also wenn es nicht einfach nur aufpoliert ist, das alte, gucken wir mal in den Trailer rein, wenn einfach nicht nur das alte aufpoliert ist, sondern wirklich auch neu gemacht wurde,
also sprich nicht einfach nur höhere Texturen rein, sondern so wie das bei der Wand hier schon aussieht, das wird es schon rechtfertigen. Ja, das sieht schon aus wie nicht rein aufgebohrt.
Man sieht jetzt auch nicht aus wie unbedingt ein Game, wenn man sich mal den Boden und so anguckt. Sieht auch nicht aus wie unbedingt ein Game von 2018. Die Haare sahen übrigens damals schon geil aus auf der PS2.
Es sieht mir aus wie so ein Zwischending. Zwischen quasi das alte ein bisschen aufpoliert und ein paar neue qualitativ höherwertigere Sachen eingefügt. Also ein Remake, aber eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht nochmal.
Ghost of, Ghost of was? Tsushima. Weil der Japaner sagt ja wahrscheinlich Tsushima oder irgendwie so. Infamous Entwickler, aha.
Einen Samurai, was ausgefallen ist. Auf die Idee gekommen, ein japanisches Spiel zu machen, wo man einen Samurai spielt, das gab es ja noch nie.
In dem die Mongoleninvasion in Japan startet, die Armee zerfällt zuerst auf Tsushima. Okay, keine Ahnung, sagt mir gar nichts. Juckt mich nicht. Mal gespannt.
Vor allem bin ich mal gespannt, wie sie das jetzt hin drehen, dass Kratos doch noch lebt. Weil ich mein, Spoiler, Kratos ist gestorben am Ende des letzten Teils.
Oder ist das gar nicht Kratos? Ist das nur einer, der zufällig so aussieht? Oder spielt man jetzt Kratos Sohn? Hat Kratos überhaupt Kinder?
God of War Story. Naja, der Typ sieht gar nicht so aus. Wobei, ja doch schon. Ist das Kratos oder ist das nicht Kratos? Das könnte ja auch ein nordischer Kratos sein.
Okay, es ist doch Kratos, steht ja auch da. Mal gucken, ob die Welt wirklich noch eine neue God of War braucht.
Verkaufszahlen werden bestimmt gut sein und Fights mit Sicherheit wieder grandios inszeniert. Spider-Man juckt mich nicht. Da bin ich gespannt drauf, soweit ich mich erinnern kann.
Ist das doch das Spiel zur damaligen Tech-Demo mit diesem Roboter, der abgeschaltet werden sollte? Wie hieß das denn?
Kara, genau. Ist das nicht das Spiel, was aus Kara damals entstanden ist? Da muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken. Ja, genau.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt drauf. Gucken, ob wieder Alan Page mit dabei ist, die dann wieder Sony verklagen kann, weil ein Nacktmodel von ihr im Game war. So ein Scheiß. So ein Blödsinn merkt man sich, ja.
Okay, was gibt es als nächstes? Was gibt es noch für Sachen? Oh, Digimon Story, ja unbedingt. Dragon Ball Fighter, blablabla. Also die Grafik sieht heulisch aus.
Haben wir uns schon angeguckt, Siegluf Banner Remake haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt. The Crew 2 juckt mich nicht. Far Cry 5 hatten wir gerade schon mal. Ist mir auch egal. Das ist so ein Mittelalter Fighting Game. Weiß nicht. Juckt mich nicht. Könnte mich interessieren.
Die Mega Man X Collection. Ist das die alten Mega Man Games? Bloß jetzt zusammen oder? Red Dead Redemption 2, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Final Fantasy Remake ist was, was ich persönlich nicht brauche. Dark Siders 3 habe ich keine hoffentliche Hoffnung drin. S-Combat 7, wenn das so gut für die alten Teile ist, dann ist das was, was mir Spaß machen könnte.
Last of Us 2, da bin ich gespannt drauf. Death Stranding, da bin ich auch gespannt drauf. Da habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch alle den Trailer geguckt und euch am Ende gefragt, okay ich habe jetzt 10 Minuten Trailer geguckt und weiß immer noch nicht, was das sein soll.
Fortnite.
Na ja, so und jetzt, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was gibt es jetzt für die Xbox? Das hält sich wahrscheinlich in Grenzen, was der Exklusives gibt.
Down 3 juckt mich nicht. Sea of Thieves juckt mich auch nicht, hatten wir gerade schon. Juckt mich auch nicht. Der erste Teil war nett. Gucken wie das wird. Das sieht für mich aus wie, wir machen das pixellig, weil die Leute denken, Pixel, Grafik ist retro und cool.
Monster Hunter World. Muss ich sagen, eine Serie, die bisher voll an mir vorbeigegangen. Ich habe Monster Hunter auf der Wii gespielt, aber ich habe nie den Reiz davon verstanden.
Und nachdem das jetzt ja auch quasi genauso Leute ansprechen sollen wie mich, die noch nie was Großartiges mit Monster Hunter am Hut hatten, bin ich mal echt gespannt drauf.
EA, Resident Sleeper. Ja und im Prinzip, der Rest ist einfach Cross-Platform hier. Metal Gear Survive, das wird grausam schlecht.
Also bis auf 3, 4, eine Handvoll Games. Darksiders 3 wird nichts. Ich sage es euch Leute, Darksiders 3 wird nichts. Das beste an Darksiders war eindeutig die Optik und sie haben den originalen Artist nicht mehr dabei.
Also den originalen Concept Art und Designer Typ. Ich weiß nicht wie er hieß. Von Darksiders 1 und 2 ist nicht mehr dabei.
Ups. So. Mit dem Chat irgendwas überlesen. Außer Diskussion was für Boards und CPUs und sonst was. Weiter gehts.
So. Den da, den da, den da. Fliege Zombies, den da, den da, den da. Und den da, den da. Ist eigentlich wurscht, kriegen wir so auch easy hin. Ach nee, Moment ich brauch Platter.
Dann nicht den da, dann den da, dann Spam da, Cactus. Cactus Spam is real. Darksiders ist mega geil. Ich glaube nicht, dass der dritte Teil gut wird.
Der erste Teil war gut, der zweite Teil war gut. Wobei der zweite Teil ganz schöne Längen hatte und die Story vom ersten Teil nicht erreicht hat.
Den ersten Teil fand ich rundum gut von Darksiders. Ich glaube nicht, dass Darksiders 3 was wird.
Allein schon, also die Hamba-Meerschen sind ein bisschen unten durch. Ich hab halt das erste Konzeptart gesehen und das erste Bild, was sie quasi veröffentlicht haben von dem Rider, den man jetzt spielt in Darksiders 3 und dann hast du direkt, ist dir direkt ins Auge gesprungen, dass das nicht mehr von dem Originaltyp erstellt wurde.
Und für mich war der Look von Darksiders eines der besten Sachen.
Aber Darksiders 3 ist doch Darksiders 1 plus 2. Quickmuffs? Wann hab ich schlauer Zuschauer?
1 plus 2 ist 3.
Big Shark. Das ist ja das Meme des Jahres der Typ.
Die meisten Mainstream-Memes finde ich ja doof, weil halt Mainstream muss man ja aus Prinzip doof finden, aber Big Shark, das find ich geil.
Oh, ich muss Kaktus pflanzen. Wenn ich kein Kaktus pflanze, dann hab ich schon das gleiche Problem wie eben. Also Kaktus. Command Pru, Kaktus.
Hammer-Oppa an und Kaktusen weiter. Kickstart-Hard.
Gibt's den Plants for Zombies eigentlich auch 1 versus 1, weil er Zombie spielt?
Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hat das Game kein Multiplayer.
Müssen wir mal im Hauptmenü gucken.
Kurz gucken, ob der jetzt eine andere Playlist... Was? Der hat eine andere Playlist angemacht, ETF. Warum?
Warum macht er einfach? Jetzt was anderes an. Ich hab gestern Auto-Play ausgeschaltet.
So, jetzt haben wir überall gekaktust.
Easy Win.
Ich glaube, du hast den Schling-Tank vergessen. Ja, den hätte ich mitnehmen können. Aber den brauchen wir nicht.
Alter, in der Weihnachtszeit gibt's einen Stream-Gewitter.
Ich hab Urlaub. Das liegt gar nicht mehr so sehr an Weihnachten, sondern weil ich jetzt den ganzen Dezember Urlaub hatte und hab.
Schreckt.
Da vorne hin noch.
Oh, so viel rot im Chat. Das hab ich jetzt übersehen.
Hast du das gekauft oder hast du es dir geholt, als es free war?
Ich hab's mir auf der Xbox damals gekauft und in Origin hab ich gestern gesehen, es ist einfach Trille gewesen.
Also ich geh mal davon aus, ich hab mir das geholt, als es free gewesen ist.
Easy Win. Easy Life. Easy Kaktus.
Huge Kaktus ist das gerade.
Massive.
Wir sitzen alle am PC während unsere Familie mit Elefanten im Wohnzimmer lauscht.
Ist auch besser so Familienstelle, das kann man auch übertreiben.
Die Delphine Sounds.
Oh, Easy Win. Jetzt kann ich Chat gucken, jetzt muss ich hier nichts mehr machen.
Guck mal, da Sebaro ist am Start.
Lasst mich raten, wenn man unbedingt Berufsschule haben will.
Es ist ja eigentlich, also zwei Gründe fallen mir da spontan ein. Entweder geht einem die Arbeit auf den Sack, was man lieber Berufsschule hat, oder man hat vielleicht irgendwelche Grills in der Klasse.
Ja, was auch immer es davon jetzt ist. Eins von beiden wird es wahrscheinlich sein, oder?
Oh, wir können uns Sonnenblumen Upgrades kaufen.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Im Prinzip können wir uns eh nur, ach kann man noch nicht klicken, Sonnenblumen Upgrades.
Wobei eigentlich habe ich immer so viele Sonnen am Ende der Runde, ich glaube ich brauche für den normalen Story-Modus überhaupt keine Sonnenblumen Upgrades.
Minigames, yeah.
Oh, ich dachte er springt jetzt nach da, ne macht er nicht.
Hochkomplexer Modus, ganz furchtbar schwierig.
Was ist das hier? Warum springst du nicht nach da?
Kackding, da muss halt der Rasenmäher auhen.
Wir hatten im ersten Lehrjahr eine Referendarin, die jetzt Englischlehrerin ist, auf die ich stehe.
Und ich bin im Englischkurs. Ich wusste es doch, dass es irgendwie sowas in der Richtung ist.
Ist doch klar. Es gibt ja eigentlich schon zwei Möglichkeiten, wenn man gerne in die Berufsschule geht.
Sind da vielleicht noch mal Zombies drin?
Easy.
Ja, Wiesbrod das stimmt. Es ist schon schlimm, wenn man instant von Echtgeld ausgeht, sobald man ein Eurozeichen in den Ingame-Shops sieht.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber das war noch vor EA Zeiten von PopCap.
Da gab es noch keine Pay2Win-Geschichten in dem Game.
Was ist denn das für Sonnenblumen? Was haben die 5K-Kosten?
Das sind Sonnenblumen-Upgrades. Da gibt es eine Sonnenblume auf einem Feld, doppelt so viel Sonne.
Kostet aber halt 150 Sonnen. Das lohnt sich in den meisten Kampagnen-Level nicht.
Die sind zu kurz in diesem Endlos-Modus oder in diesem Challenge-Modus lohnt sich das dann auf jeden Fall.
Sehr schweres Minigame. Massive schwer.
So, easy geschafft.
Was ist eine Pflanze, die braucht man nie?
Anstatt Solar-Panels auf dem Dach einfach Sonnenblumen pflanzieren, so einfach kann es sein.
Es ist eigentlich egal, ob man Sonnenblumen oder Pilze nimmt.
Wir haben keine Fliege-Zombie. Wir haben diese... Ach, deswegen hat man das hier gekriegt, weil hier diese Maulwurf-Buddel-Zombie-Dinger am Start sind.
Aber die sind so einfach. Die können auch ein paar Sonnenblumen wegfressen oder ein paar Pilze, das ist egal.
Bauen wir mal wieder Tribble-Nators.
Was vergessen, das brauchen wir noch. Und jetzt nehmen wir als letztes noch... BÄM. BUM. Nehmen wir mit. Big Shack. BUM.
Ja, das stimmt.
Hast du durchgeschossen durch die Gegner? Weiß nicht, wie es jetzt ist in Battlefield 1.
Previously, ich glaube, das ist recht unwahrscheinlich.
Gibt es Statistiken von Twitch über die Grill-Quote? Gute Frage.
Ich habe mir die Analyse-Seiten von Twitch noch nie angeschaut.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es sowas gibt. Weil wenn jemand diesen Stream optimieren will, was auch immer man da jetzt genau darunter versteht.
Es ist nicht schlecht zu wissen, wer zuguckt, in welchem Alter, welches Geschlecht. Nicht verkehrt.
Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich sowas gibt in den Twitch-Statistiken.
Ich habe auch, wie gesagt, einen leger Koks.
In Bot-Befehl habe ich genau deswegen eingeführt.
Was? Hör auf, Zombie. Geh weg. Piss dich, Alte.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal hier ein bisschen Sonnensammel und Tribble-Nators pflanzen.
Oh, der Rätsel-Modus. So, so.
Oh, da ist er hier. Da stellt es da.
Ich kann gar nichts machen.
Sonnensammel für Tribble-Nators. Huge Tribble-Nators.
Mikro-SD-Karten bekommst du auf Amazon hinterhergeworfen.
Generell sind Flash-Geschichten, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade terabyteweise ist, ziemlich günstig geworden.
Das ist aus den letzten Jahren zum Glück eins der besten Erfindungen aller Zeiten.
Schauen wir noch so ein Dinger.
Easy Level.
Easy, easy. Da muss man gar nichts machen.
Da bin ich eigentlich schon on. Ich werde echt müde gerade.
Erst eine Stunde.
Ich glaube, das mit BDO-Kreisel-Level lassen wir heute.
Irgendwie bin ich im Arsch. Wahrscheinlich zu viel gefressen.
Keine Fliege-Zombies. Aber wir pilzen einfach mal ordentlich auf hier.
Ordentlich aufgepilzt.
Die Dinger habe ich nie verwendet, diese Sternfrucht-Teile. Keine Ahnung, ob die was taugen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so easy win.
Okay, da ist jetzt sogar noch mehr Nebel. Da brauchen wir das auf jeden Fall, das Teilnetz.
Morgen ist auch noch ein Tag. Ja, das stimmt. Dann mache ich auch gleich Schluss.
Ich bin echt kaputt gerade. Jetzt setzt so voll das Koma ein.
Außerdem ist ja morgen immer noch Weihnachten.
Jetzt wo wir uns gerade die Spiele angeguckt haben für PC, Xbox und PS4, wo jetzt ja für mich jetzt nicht so viel Hype-Sachen dabei waren.
Gibt es denn für euch irgendwas, worauf ihr euch richtig freut? Game-technisch.
Also nächstes Jahr.
Ist das die Vape Nation Map? Weißt du nicht, was die Zombies hier offscreen machen?
Monster oder für den PC? Okay.
Ja, da bin ich auch gespannt drauf. Wie gesagt, zumal es ja diesmal so gemacht sein soll, dass es eben auch genau Leute wie mich anspricht, die nichts bisher mit der Reihe Cross am Hut hatten.
Battlefront 3 Fan-Made auf Basis von was?
Das klingt interessant. Also das klingt spannend.
Auf welcher Basis wird das gemacht? Also was ist da grundlagetechnisch?
Ja, Darksiders, aber du hast es gerade kaputt gemacht. Wie gesagt, ich habe halt nicht so die großen Hoffnungen in Darksiders 3.
Half-Life 3, ganz bestimmt, ja.
2018 ist das Jahr für Half-Life 3. Ich habe es im Urin.
Ich fühle es schon quasi. Half-Life 3. Das muss ich dann auch let's playen über die nächsten zwei Jahre.
Das neue Elder Scrolls. Kommt doch kein neues Elder Scrolls.
Es gibt bestimmt wieder das 85. Skyrim Remake. Also soweit ich weiß, kommt 2018 kein neues Elder Scrolls. Die haben doch sogar erst erzählt, sie wollen in nächster Zeit kein neues Elder Scrolls machen.
Der Source wurde mal geliegt, Milchmann.
Da gibt es ja dann auch ein gutes neues Battlefront.
Ich sehe es schon kommen, wenn ich sehe, wie fett Games mittlerweile sind und ich mich manchmal, ich frage mich manchmal warum.
Also ich meine ja selbst große Texturen und, aber um auf 50 Gigabyte zu kommen, da musst du dich schon echt anstrengen.
Oder komplett unkomprimiertes Audio noch reinhauen und sowas.
Keine Ahnung, was wieder abgeht. Plants vs. Zombies ist 250 MB.
Und das ist ein komischer Flashport, da könnte er wahrscheinlich noch viel kleiner sein.
Quantum Break 70. 70 Gigabyte, allen Ernst, ich habe mir das ja Bastille vor zwei Tagen gekauft, äh ne gestern, gestern gekauft.
70. Na gut, da ist schon zwei Terabyte, das ist der aber. Endlich hat es mal den Sinn.
Hast du auch mal Plants vs. Zombies Garden Warfare gezockt? Ja, fand ich gut.